Using the process that I just
showed you, I went ahead and
made up a little bit of a draft for
the rules that I think we might
want to use in ShoppingList++.
And I just outlined them in English,
because I'm going to want you
to eventually implement these.
Now, just as a caveat,
I know this is not a complete list.
I'm sure there's plenty of
additional validation rules,
and maybe some read-write rules
that you can add into this.
But it's at least a start.
Okay, so let's take a look.
I started off with the users note here.
And it probably looks
pretty darn familiar.
I think the biggest
thing to point out is,
I went ahead and indented this
hasLoggedInWithPassword property.
And I tried my best to
do some indentation
to imply where I think
the rule should be placed.
But as always, use your best
judgment about rule placement.
The rules pretty much follow
what I explained before.
So let's go ahead take
a look at userLists next.
Scroll down, and this is for
a specific user.
I decided that we're probably
not going to have read or
write rules for the entire list
of all user lists in the app.
But for a single user shopping list,
there is a read rule,
and it basically says that each user
should be able to read their own lists.
But there's no real reason why any other
user should be able to read another
user's shopping lists.
That's probably a bit of
a privacy concern if they could.
Now I didn't put a write rule at this
level, because that would basically say
that somebody could do a bulk write,
like write three shopping lists at once.
And you never really do that in the app.
You always write one list at a time,
which is why down here I have
a write rule for a single list.
For single lists that
are part of a user list,
you need to give specific
write privileges.
And what this permission here is
basically saying, is that the owner of
the shopping list, which is different
than the owner that I mention here.
But the owner of the specific shopping
list that's being written can add that
list, or can delete that list.
So an example of this is that within the
app, the delete menu option should only
be visible to the owner
of that shopping list.
So say Kaguri has a shopping list
that she creates called list A, and
she shares it with Walter and myself.
Now she's the owner of
that shopping list.
But that shopping list
is now in Walter and
my user lists,
because we have access to it.
As the owner of the list, she has the
permission to be able to go ahead and
delete that shopping list.
And she then needs to go into
each of our user lists and
delete that shopping
list from our user lists.
And with this write rule she
should be allowed to do that,
because she's the owner of
that specific shopping list.
Okay, but note that we don't give any
editing privileges at this level.
And that's because I didn't want to
make it so that all of the properties of
a shopping list could be edited or
editable in the same way.
So down here for
each of these properties, I define
who can edit them more explicitly.
And I also have a couple of
additional validate rules
that go beyond the structural
stuff that we talked about before.
Okay, so next, our shopping list items.
There's no part of the app where you're
reading all shopping list items in
every single shopping list.
So again, this is for
a specific shopping list.
Anyone who is shared on the list, or
the owner of the list itself,
should be able to read the items, so
that they can be displayed in the active
list details activity, activity.
Writing is a little bit more
complicated since it varies
from property to property.
Since you add items one at a time, the
only write action that can be done for
the whole list is to delete it.
Anyone who's shared on the list
could add a single item.
And furthermore, if the item is not
bought, I say that either the owner of
the list or the owner of the item
can remove or edit the item.
This is not entirely true, since in
the app the owner cannot edit items.
But for the sake of brevity, the rules
won't specify that you can't do that.
Again, if you want to take
the time to get a little bit more
specific in the rules, that's awesome.
Okay, so just as I did with user lists,
I go down here to the specific
properties and have some additional
write and validate rules.
For example, we have validate rules that
make sure that if an item is bought,
it has a boughtBy user.
Okay, let's go down to
the sharedWith node.
Like items, the sharedWith node is
tied to a specific shopping list.
And this node needs to be readable
by anybody that is on the list,
because every time you
update a list property,
we have this lookup where you see
who else is shared on the list, and
then use that to then update
everybody else's shopping list.
Writing to the shared list,
which basically means the ability
to share that list and add and
remove users, is restricted to
the owner of the shopping list.
And they can either completely add
a user or completely remove a user, but
they can't edit specific
properties of users,
which is why I explicitly say add and
remove.
Finally, userFriends is
restricted both read and
write to just the user that
owns that list of userFriends.
Okay so this is just a draft summary
of the rules that I came up with, and
again if you think there are a couple of
additional rules that you'd like to add,
definitely go for it.
I encourage you to add them and
make ShoppingList++ more secure.